in the world of superheroes death is
simply a passing inconvenience if your
favorite character dies a horrible yet
heroic death well it might sting for a
bit but don't worry they'll be back
sooner or later with that in mind here's
a spoiler filled look at some of the
superheroes we lost so far in 2017 rest
in peace
for now Logan Wolverine has been one of
the most popular superheroes in the
world for decades thanks in large part
to Hugh Jackman who has portrayed the
character in nine movies since the year
2000 in 2017 though Jackman appeared in
what he swears is his final film as
Wolverine headlining the grim Logan
fittingly Jackman's final appearance as
Wolverine ended with Logan's death turns
out the adamantium grafted to his bones
didn't just make him indestructible it
also was slowly poisoning him pushing
his mutant healing factor beyond its
capabilities so when Logan faced off
against an evil clone his battered body
finally gave up the ghost but not before
he Allah saved a group of mutant kids
including a totally different totally
not evil little girl clone so at least
some of Logan lives on somewhere even if
it might be a little too confusing to
understand Professor Charles Xavier
dedicated to the proposition that all
men are created equal
Professor Xavier has been pursuing his
dream since 1963 and for the better part
of two decades Patrick Stewart has been
one of the pair of actors portraying the
good professor on the big screen
sadly the professor's dream turned into
a nightmare in the film Logan after
suffering a seizure that accidentally
caused him to kill all his own students
Xavier was put into a drugged stupor by
his last remaining pupil
Logan Professor X's pain finally came to
an end when Logan's evil clone killed
him right in the middle of a road trip
to the woods of North Dakota that seems
like a fittingly convoluted way for the
original x-man to die Jack flag first
debuting back in 1994 Jack Harrison was
originally a member of a citizens patrol
group who responded to reports submitted
at Captain America's danger hotline but
during a fight with mr. Hyde he got
drenched in super chemicals and became a
real-deal super-powered hero under the
name Jack flag after bouncing around the
Marvel Universe for two decades even
joining the guardians of the galaxy at
one point Jack flag has on-and-off-again
partner free spirit were eventually
recruited by Captain America the joint
shield
unknown to them however Steve had been
turned evil by the reality warping
powers of the Cosmic Cube and was
actually working for Hydra
Jack discovered this the hard way when
Steve Rogers tossed him out of a plane
Jack survived the fall but was left
brain dead until free spirit decided to
pull the plug
jack we hoist a patriotic face bandana
to your memory hack when you join a team
called The Suicide Squad you have to
know your time is limited the superhero
known as hack found this out the hard
way a tech-savvy metahuman who grew up
in the slums of Nairobi PAC had the
unique ability to interact with
computers using her mind allowing her to
surf the web and download information
directly into her head as well as turn
people in a digital code and transport
them through the internet but rather
than simply use her power to binge watch
YouTube hack decided to help the Suicide
Squad along the way she accidentally
discovered that the team had traitors in
their midst before she could reveal the
shocking information one of those
traitors Captain Boomerang stabbed her
to death
alas poor hack we hardly knew ye
Patriot when it comes to classic
superheroes it doesn't get much more
old-school than Jeffrey mace the Patriot
who first debuted back in 1941
that was heyday in the comics ended long
ago the Patriot got a second lease on
life thanks to marvel's agents of shield
where he appeared in season four as a
spy agency's new director blessed with
powers thanks to a Super Soldier Serum
mace ended up entering the virtual
reality program called the framework in
order to rescue some of his agents and
just like in the matrix if you die in
the framework you die in reality - while
Mays performed a rescue inside the
program Madame Hydra blew up the
building he was in mace was able to use
his powers to save everyone else in the
building and give them time to escape
but at the cost of his own life
I hear Jeffy hang on Bucky Barnes
the Winter Soldier it used to be one
basic rule when it came to bring him
back dead characters everyone could
return except for Peter Parker's Uncle
Ben and Captain America's sidekick Bucky
Barnes who died while trying to defuse
one of baron zemo's
flying bombs during World War two that
rule was famously violated though when
Bucky returned from the dead is the
Soviet sleeper super agent the Winter
Soldier however all good things must
come to an end
including Bucky's second life after
Captain America was turned evil by the
Cosmic Cube evil Steve Rogers teamed up
with the new Baron Zemo they captured
Bucky and in a cruel twist reenacted his
original death by strapping into a
replica of that same flying bomb and
blow em sky-high don't worry though
he'll probably be back after all it's
happened before okay
who the hell is buck thanks for watching
click the looper I kind of subscribe to
our YouTube channel plus check out all
this cool stuff we know you'll love too
[Music]